um rosebud are you the type to over
share when you're nervous and just throw
it all out there
or are you more like keep stuff in no i
won't tell anyone anything if any i'm
more like i'll just i'll get the lay of
the land first
and then if i feel good i'll open up you
know what i mean yeah like i was on i i
did ktla this morning and i got i closed
my computer and i was like who was that
like
oh really who was i just now it was the
most i was smiling the whole time and my
voice was really high
country club yeah i did this weird like
country club it was like i was
auditioning for a commercial it was the
weirdest yeah version of myself and i i
shut the computer and i was just like
ugh like i i hope that's not the rest of
my head yeah you know and uh
so i i can sort of shape shift i i grew
up like with money around wealthy white
people and you and you just don't you
don't talk about your feelings like that
so you grew up in a an affluent
very much so yeah my grandad was like uh
worked in the white house he was like
secretary of state for george bush
senior what jim baker yeah is your gra
is my grandfather
i have a picture of him no no no no no
no wait i have a picture can i ask you
this yes i've always wanted to know
is jim baker sober
no okay no not at all because i'll tell
you why okay because there was a gym
baker in my men's meeting in san diego
and i always they looked exactly the
same yeah it's always thought that maybe
that was him but no it's not right but i
know who jim baker is so you come from
heavy
political yeah pedigree succession yeah
my family yeah let me see the phone i'll
show you the photo country clubbing [ __ ]
i know this is the real thing i
literally have a photo of me at the
white house with george bush
senior no no no no no on christmas no no
no
yeah yeah
oh my god where are you
that's you right there yeah
i'm looking terrified oh my god yeah
you're really a part now is your
grandfather still alive uh yeah he's
still alive does he know what you do
yeah
is he proud i mean
i wouldn't call it that i mean maybe i
don't know i really don't know i it does
wow we look exactly the same
that's actually terrifying yeah yeah
that's horrible that's your granddad
yeah that's insane yeah
so um
but he knows you do comedy right he
knows i do comedy he has seen a couple
sets i talked about him uh in one of my
sets
uh
and
because i had to address it like i can't
not
like i couldn't talk at all about
politics without talking about that
first because that set the stage for
how i felt like my political affiliation
and where i was
gonna go and like he's a republican yeah
yeah yeah and staunch yes and wouldn't
like
weirdly like wouldn't come out against
trump wouldn't like did the whole like
towed the party line like like
republicans do and
it was uh
it was a very weird thing to i kept
trying to ask like how do you feel about
this and
the worst thing that he would say is
that he's
he's like at least half crazy
that's that's all he said
but he wouldn't he wouldn't really ever
speak ill of him and uh and my granddad
is is like that he's a he's a politician
like
he is a politician through and through
but you know how he really feels
no no i mean you really don't no i i've
had a lot of experience with giving men
more credit than they deserve
i i just i can't really do that you know
what i mean i can't go
well he this is how he really i don't
know how he really feels oh
it's a lock it's a locked box you know
he's like my dad i mean my dad was
korean and i had knew nothing about how
he felt about anything yeah and it's
just a locked box yeah and there's no
way to figure it out you know i'm sure
deep down inside there is stuff but it's
buried and i just don't have the time or
willingness it's like that's like dave
cho one of our friends um he's in his
40s now he's finally in a place where he
feels like he doesn't know his father
even though like he's close to his
father right and they um you know he
went up to his father and he was like
hey like i want to know who you are i
want to know your feelings
like are you open to that or do you want
to keep it as is yeah the dad was like
keep it as it yeah he's like no we're
not going there yeah
yeah
if you were homeless
right
could you call your granddad and go can
i stay with you guys for a couple weeks
yeah i'll get good yeah i could do that
you could do that i could reach out to
his secretary
can you send me his number
because i i i don't have his number i
don't have his number i mean i should
have his number my sisters have his
number yeah but i don't
i just don't call him that often and
like
i
have a very complicated relationship
with family where i'm just like i don't
know the value of
family like
as a person i don't understand
our connection to it
my